let's get more now with correspondent
your browser who is joining us from
Tehran he is a correspondent with the
German public broadcaster at CDF York we
saw the regime bringing out tens of
thousands of supporters over the weekend
how are these tough sanctions likely to
affect support for Iran's leader leaders
well what we saw the pictures we saw on
the week and of course was a well staged
propaganda show organized by the Iranian
government as you said they shipped
thousands of people from all over the
country to Tehran to send out a strong
signal of national unity but if you talk
to the people the majority I think is of
course dissatisfied with the performance
of the rouhani government the people saw
the prices going up over the last couple
of month they saw the value of the
national currency going down and many
might lose their jobs in the next weeks
so the people are disappointed but to my
impression the potential of
disappointment is still not big enough
to be taken to the streets and on the
political level Washington says that its
sanctions that they're aimed at curbing
Iran's ballistic missile and nuclear
programs and what it calls support for
terror so ultimately do you think that
we're likely to see the regime backing
down there in Iran we're referring to
the public statements made by both the
rouhani government and the religious
leadership I'd say no I mean President
rouhani went on television this morning
and he repeated that the Iranian
government is not ready to talk to the
United States as long as they keep up
their precondition I think it's it's
about finding a face-saving way for
bringing the Iranian leadership to the
negotiating table and to include the
conventional weapons because after the
lift of the sanctions in 2015 Iran
substantially beefed up their support
for the Lebanese Hezbollah militia they
are now posing a massive threat to
Israel and this is in my opinion the
actual background for the u.s.
reimposing the sanctions but at the
moment I think Iran is not ready to talk
about their conventional weapons and of
course Tehran says that it's going to
get around these sanctions but how
exactly are they planning on doing
well there are certain measures that
have been taken over the last couple of
days I don't think that the Iranians
really count on European support so what
they did is for for example they
reopened a chamber of the Tehran Stock
Exchange trying to bring buyers and
sellers together of oil and anaemia Slee
and then there's another story that
there have been about 11 million barrels
of crude oil being stored on tankers in
the Persian Gulf the Iranian oil tankers
switched of their Raider in order not to
be found and tracked but on the other
hand the US have established a task
force trying to detect these loopholes
and prevent Iran from generating income
so I think what we are going to see over
the next couple of weeks is kind of a
hide-and-seek game between Tehran and
Washington cdf correspond in york
browser with the view from tehran thank
you and iran says that it is working
with europe to set up a mechanism to
bypass those sanctions let's bring in
brussels correspondent teri Schultz teri
could this actually happen the European
Union maintains that it will happen just
Friday
federica mogherini you foreign policy
chief and the governments of France
Germany and the UK said that their
resolve to both maintain the nuclear
deal with Iran and to maintain economic
support for European companies doing
business in Iran is unwavering so the
European Union says it's setting up this
so-called special purpose vehicle which
would allow payments to go in and out of
Iran and bypassing US sanctions that's
how how its envisioned and the EU
maintains that this is going to happen
although it's not operational today at
the same time the US has yet another
lever and that is to demand that Swift
that's the Belgium based financial
messaging service which handles most of
the world's interbank messaging the US
says Swift has to cut off all the
sanctions Iranian institutions and so if
that happens it's hard to see how it
could get around the sanctions
regardless of how creative they're being
how about European companies themselves
because we know that the United States
has threatened them if they don't adhere
to these sanctions are they likely to do
so or not yes we have seen European
companies pulling out of Iran and that's
despite the EU itself threatening
sanctions on companies that pull out in
it because of the US sanctions so these
companies are really in a tough spot
because both Brussels and Washington are
saying they must obey but what we have
seen is is an exodus of European
companies and some very big German
companies among them deciding that
simply their bottom line cannot support
being in a confrontation with Washington
and that whatever losses they have to
take by cutting contracts in Iran and
and possibly annoying Brussels is going
to be worth it DW is teri Schultz with
some initial indications here of how
these sanctions are likely to impact
European business Thank You teri